en este vídeo vamos a tomar nuestros
motores de 5 volts y vamos a construir
unas monturas para los motores con los
palitos de madera estos nos permitirán
colocar los motores juntos y asegurarnos
de que se alinean perfectamente y
también nos dará una base en donde poner
nuestras baterías vamos a medir la
distancia y parece que necesitamos dos
pulgadas y media o unos seis centímetros
así que vamos a cortar el palito de
madera a esta medida con las pinzas
alicate una vez que cortamos un palito
seis centímetros cortaremos otro con la
misma medida
estas piezas nos van a permitir conectar
nuestros motores y mantener todo bien
alineado el que sean palitos de madera
es bueno porque el silicón caliente no
seca inmediatamente por lo que tenemos
algo de tiempo para acomodar la posición
de las piezas si pusiéramos el silicón
caliente directo en el metal del motor
se enfriaría casi inmediatamente y no
nos permitiría hacer ajustes cortamos
bien los bordes de los palitos de madera
y queremos asegurarnos de que los
autores estén perfectamente bien
alineados así que ponemos el pedazo de
madera arriba para alinear todo es
importante que este pedazo de madera no
sobresalga de los motores ya que si
sobresale vamos a tener problemas para
que giren las ruedas los motores son
magnéticos y son atraídos por la regla
de metal por lo que la regla nos ayuda a
mantener los motores en su lugar también
podemos ver los contactos y tenemos que
asegurarnos que ambos queden hacia abajo
esto es muy importante ya que si quedan
hacia arriba ya que si quedan hacia
arriba cuando pegamos el palito de
madera pues no podremos que hablar el
motor por lo que tendremos que quitar el
palito de madera así que ponemos el
silicón caliente en el palito no en los
motores porque nos permite un poco más
de tiempo para ajustar su posición al
pegarlo volteamos el palito de madera y
lo colocamos en su lugar aquí tengan
cuidado porque el silicón caliente pues
está muy caliente y les puede quemar
nuevamente asegúrense de que los motores
están alineados usa
la regla de metal si lo están ustedes
tendrán todo perfectamente alineado por
eso es importante que nuestra regla sea
metálica para que nos ayude a mantener
alineados los motores nuestra regla
tiene que ser de acero la de aluminio no
nos va a servir para este propósito ya
que no es magnética ahora vamos a cortar
nuestros cables unas 6 pulgadas o 15
centímetros
vamos a necesitar 4 cables de 15
centímetros cada uno dos negros y dos
rojos
ahora vamos a pelar los extremos unos 6
milímetros y ahora usaremos nuestras
pinzas de nariz de aguja para torcer las
puntas de nuestros cables en un lazo y
luego vamos a doblar ligeramente el lazo
y lo hacemos así porque nos ayudará a
insertarlos en los motores cada motor
tiene una pequeña conexión que nos
permitirá sujetar el cable para
mantenerlo en su lugar cuando insertamos
el cable este se debe sentir bastante
justo este no quedó muy justo así que lo
sacamos y ajustamos el lazo y lo
empujamos contra esta pestaña de metal
en el motor así que queremos que esa
pestaña de metal sostenga el cable en su
lugar queremos que el cable quede bien
ajustado incluso podemos usar nuestro
destornillador para empujar el cable un
poco más ya que no queremos que los
cables se caigan ahora hacemos lo mismo
para el otro lado
ya que tenemos ambos lados conectados
tomamos nuestro silicón caliente y
hacemos lo mismo que hicimos con el otro
segmento de madera pero ahora lo ponemos
de este otro lado lo que nos va a ayudar
a mantener a los motores en su lugar y
también a los cables los sostenemos así
por unos minutos hasta que haya
endurecido por completo y el silicón
tenga un tono lechoso antes de soltarlo
de otra manera se puede mover de su
lugar ahora tomamos nuestras pilas las
ponemos en su lugar quitamos los
protectores de las baterías y vamos a
ponerlas casi entre los motores de esta
forma y queremos que se alineen de
manera que el peso esté balanceado si
las baterías quedan hacia uno de los
lados el peso no estará balanceado y la
araña no podrá moverse con suavidad así
es como se debe ver una batería estará
viendo hacia un lado y la otra batería
estará viendo hacia el otro lado es
importante que todas las piezas se
recarguen por completo en la mesa lo que
quiere decir que los motores deben
bien alineados pues de no ser así las
ruedas no van a quedar bien asentadas en
el suelo cuando encendamos nuestro robot
ya que está todo bien asentado colocamos
silicón caliente en nuestro palito de
madera la cantidad suficiente para que
abarque lo largo de la batería y
queremos que el pegamento esté en el
centro del palito una vez que tenemos
esto alineado nos aseguramos de que todo
quede bien asentado en la mesa y
sujetamos nuestra batería contra la
madera y apretamos todas las piezas
juntas para que se alinean las apretamos
bien y volvemos a asegurarnos que todo
quede bien asentado en la mesa tanto los
motores como las baterías
y aunque es fácil equivocarse lo bueno
del silicón caliente es que siempre
podemos separarlo y empezar de nuevo si
es necesario ahora hacemos lo mismo
del otro lado ponemos silicón caliente
en el centro del otro palito con la
longitud suficiente para abarcar la
batería
y nos aseguramos de que está queda bien
alineada en el centro de nuestros
motores y directamente alineada con la
otra batería lo apretamos todo junto y
de nuevo nos aseguramos que todo toque
completamente la superficie de la mesa y
si tienen un compañero él o ella pueden
asegurarse de que todo queda bien
asentado en la mesa esto es muy
importante ya que nos facilitará
muchísimo poder colocar la cinta de
doble cara en la parte de abajo para
pegar el cuerpo de la araña a los
motores y las baterías bien así es como
debe verse el ensamblado de nuestros
motores y nuestras baterías